we have a guest with christian
we are indeed with a lady that won her
third consecutive game congratulations
jennifer welcome back take us through
the feelings that you have right now um
thank you so
i
honestly don't really know how to feel
about my game i i think um i was
definitely pretty happy with my position
at the opening because i mean she kind
of just gave me a pawn and it was like
okay so it's like a kind of like a plane
for two results
um and then at some point i like i think
i made it a little bit too complicated i
was missing some details here and there
so i tried to like fix it with like
teenage seven um i played that
but
i don't i gave her some time i'm not
exactly sure what the evaluation
position was it was really complicated
and i like i spent too much of my time
so then i was just like you know what i
will just play this and i think the
first surprise for us is that you chose
the relopus instead of your usual
sicilian
how did you come up with that strategy
um no i do play this like more often but
i don't play like the um this knight f6
very early because i looked at her um
when i prepared her she always plays
like d3 right away so i was like okay i
mean i didn't have anything that special
but um that's what i was expecting and
said she did um
yes she did
well she did d3 after
um castles and well i i wanted to well
my prep was i was to play some like
briar but i don't think there's like
nine on c3 so then i wasn't really sure
what to do but i think this was okay i
also i don't know um exactly the opening
but i thought like knight f4 instead of
h3 might have been just like
pull up like
i like that better for white but maybe
it's just the idea being that you go h3
now and you don't have any squares for
that bishop yeah because i was afraid of
getting uh
bad bishop versus goodnight
right and then she kind of um made sure
that didn't happen so which really was
really nice for me and she gave you this
pawn with e5 but you took it with the
bishop and now
instead of taking with the knight did
you consider a queen to e2 first yeah
that was my um that was what i expected
uh so i was really surprised when she
took on e5 and also when she played
rookie one because i thought queenie two
um i mean here rookie one makes sense
it's not rookie four
but
i i
the opening of the queen side um did
help me a bit because otherwise i think
she could just take the pawn pretty
easily so this was just some counter
play
now you're upon up but obviously there's
some clear compensation and quite a
difficult path at work towards making
any progress at this point
were you playing for uh for for a win
right now yeah um i mean i did like my
position i mean it's definitely a little
bit difficult but like when you um if
you go back a few moves and when i
played king h7 that was just because
like i wanted to play um queen c1 but uh
there i think there's rope takes e4
um
and then like i was looking roxy too but
i just don't have enough time rook to e8
and then queen e4 i think
and then white just stops everything and
let's show that maybe queen to c1 rook
to d4 no no at that point
instead of king h7 quick c1 yeah rook
takes d4
yeah because it just works out perfectly
for us
yeah rook c2 rook d8 king h7 and now
queen to e4
and uh
yeah don't get to her
to her king yeah i'm just like a move
too slow i think because then rook d7
uh-huh yes that looks very conclusive
after rook d7
nice calculation and you decide to uh
prepare that with the moving to h7
now i want to take you to this uh
moment rook to b7
queen to c1 king to h6 so you repeat it
once
and then with one minute on the clock
you play the move king to h6
were you worried
that she has something at this point and
did you see anything um i i think i saw
some things uh well even after she tried
the works off i think white is okay
there there should be some moves did you
see this move rook f7 right now no i
wasn't expecting rook f7 does it
yeah what is happening
um
so i i guess the idea is
uh
rook
rook situations
yes and then i think you have to force
this end game with queen to f4
quinto f4 which is still
probably slightly better for you but
very much close to equality yeah i mean
that was kind of like a worst case
scenario if queen g4 ever happened i
always have queen f4 um like i couldn't
figure out like obviously i couldn't
figure out for sure if whatever kh 6 was
safe or not but
i mean
i have this position and i just if i
took a draw here i would just feel
horrible so yeah i mean i i think it was
worth the risk even though i definitely
should not have done this with like one
minute on the clock
no i think it was a good decision
practically um
king to g6 was indeed just because
you're not allowing rook f7 was the more
precise move but king h6 still
a fighter's move at this point rook to
b6 rook to c6
we were surprised by rook to c6
yeah rook to c2 it seems like it would
have uh won the game right now
um
i would assume you calculate the truth
to c2 yeah but i wasn't sure so rook
takes e6 um g6 and then i think queen g
going to g4 queen to f4
queen f4 oh and then just now the h4 is
stuck
wait i thought i looked at this
what did i do
yeah
oh right right yeah this is right i
played rook c6 because i was playing
this right away and then um i just
played rook c6 because i was like i
can't figure out for sure if i'm not
missing anything well you also had like
30 seconds on the clock yeah but yeah i
remember because i thought if she played
rook b8 um i would do
what can play rookies
that's a different thing she played rook
b8 here i think you can play roxy too
there's rook h5 right
oh rh5 king g6 queen g4 yeah
this works
yeah so i would have to play g6 after v8
mm-hmm
good point
yeah and once again whenever she goes
queen g4 you go queen four and you go
into that winning game game
very nice but
it seemed like she was getting close to
achieving equality did you feel that way
yeah i did but um i mean
here i'm not so sure about this g4
um i mean the second she let my pawn to
be three i thought i had just much
better chances
i don't know
objectively what it is but also we were
both getting low here on time
and after this i think i think this end
game has to be winning it's winning okay
definitely nicely done yeah
jennifer congratulations now four out of
five in a convention a conventional
tournament would be a pretty high score
but there is one lady on a perfect score
five out of five you're going to be
playing her in round seven
are you already looking to that forward
to that match-up
yeah i mean she's playing very really
well so i think it'd be an interesting
game
um
but yeah i mean i
kind of believe in like
like making your own luck so like
if i have a shot against her then i have
to take it
perfect congratulations uh jennifer
we'll see you after the rest day
our congratulations as well jennifer